i was pissed i was in san diego i'll
never forget that
[ __ ] that dude
[Music]
hey i'm mario lopez would you rather a
be permanently hungover or b
never be able to drink again oh you love
that tequila oh man i i mean gotta hang
what's that when you get a mean hangover
though and when you you guys you'll see
when you get older [ __ ] it's a mean one
to get over like i used to be able to
party
i remember party all night two three
more get up still work out boom go about
my day now i can go hard and i need like
three to recover yeah three to like find
to feel normal again
i don't know if i could be permanently
hungover i'll be honest with you that i
just be miserable i'd just be miserable
i might not be able to drink again i'd
i'd substitute it with other substances
if i had to these are hypothetical these
are hypothetical would you rather spend
the rest of your life in a country music
video or a rap music video ooh
both of those videos a lot of fun
i i i go back to like diddy in the 90s
if i go back to like i would have to go
uh a rap music video but specifically
something with like
diddy in the 90s on a yacht champagne
flowing
just kind of bouncing and oh yeah i'm
not opposed to the country music after
uh spending some time in nashville
though that's popping too what you know
about going out getting wet yeah
would you rather have your internet
history made public or a sex tape that
goes viral oh you can make my internet
history public all day i'm boring yeah i
don't i don't yeah i don't look up any
yeah i know i looked up where i look up
a lot of words definition not too much
spelling but like that yeah but that's
about it but i'm not like not not like
anything like naughty or bad or anything
what was the other option i forgot what
the other option was or make a sex tape
no no no
although i would be able to capitalize
on that
if i could broke no no keep it like that
all right could you beat tom cruise in a
fight come on man come on that's easy
come on i love tom cruise but he's gonna
want to throw hands
i literally like i'm either boxing or
doing jiu jitsu every day literally
every day so yeah time time i feel like
tom would catch that fade real quick
you don't want that smoke what's the
worst thing you've gotten thrown out of
a bar for i remember one time i was at a
country bar too i was young
and um he said i was he said i had drank
too much when i which i didn't okay
because i don't eat anyone no i didn't
because even when i drink too much i'm
never i'm not a sloppy dude i'm not a
sloppy i'm never like inappropriate i
know how to handle my liquor so that's
what i think he liked the chick i was
talking to but he blamed it on that and
i got thrown out i was pissed i was in
san diego i'll never forget that
[ __ ] that dude if you could be any
character from a tv show who would you
be
ooh
um i don't know why game of thrones came
to mind like just be like
king joffrey like just or whatever
you're going to say to just how someone
went like this yeah because there's some
or someone from that area or something i
only want to live until i'm 30.
would you rather give up the hungover
breakfast sandwich or the drunk pizza um
oh that's tough
i'd have to give up the
hungover i don't have to give up the
drunk pizza because when i'm was like
because i'm hammered on anything to mess
up that buzz i just want to crash out
and i wake up hungry and so i don't have
to give that up i don't want to sweep
myself up
no no i want to stay i want to stay off
cause then you sleep better wait because
i when i eat after i've been drinking i
feel all my stuff feels all [ __ ] like
you know then you're like murdering
toilets and stuff that's not
you don't want i'd rather not give up
though yeah you get all right you get
all tore up you're all tore up the next
day who is the worst group of fans
raider fans
are the worst group of fans that's cause
i'm a charger fan out there that's some
west coast stuff right there anytime
there's a raider fan raiders had to move
out of valet because they were bringing
down the real estate
and the crime was getting too high
so outside there in vegas now
no love for the raiders these are fun if
you had to get by the way you know how
hard it is for me not have to do this
trying to be i'm trying to be cool
if you had to get one movie quote
tattooed on your body what would it be
oh damn there's so many good ones oh god
there's so many i'd probably have to get
one a rocky quote the what what i'm
gonna have to go rocky quote but one of
my favorite movie scenes is when rocky's
telling um his son who was played by
milo and similar i think his rocky five
it was a sun
life ain't all sunshine and rainbows it
will beat you down it will hurt you and
it's all about getting up i'd hit that
whole though i have a mural on my back
by talking to my kid i'll just go like
this
that's the best right there
thank you for watching answer the
internet with mario lopez please
subscribe to the channel comment below
on other celebrities you'd like to see
and make sure you hit the bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out